hello and welcome to this video am jean
wise the opponent no name let's go
playing the two knights against his karo
I'm not a huge expert if he takes the
pawn and kind of making things up before
why is that good
it looks like wrongly time move to be
honest he cannot cancel now because of
Bishop h6 okay so he lost two moves
there um I probably use this time to and
consolidate the center yeah what to do
here I mean I can take I don't know
maybe Bishop III is also possible I
don't know if he wants to take on b2 m41
would be 7 that looks quite dangerous to
take yeah maybe could have taken but he
didn't um okay now taking Goodwin the
Queen so oh really really
what about 93 in this position for
Knight B 5 and so on um okay
takes this no taking on defaults
wouldn't work in Queen a form I should
win win the substantial material and if
it takes 95 is basically winning a four
okay so night the five doesn't work I
mean at least not doesn't win stuff it's
quadriga five
Bishop is fine is a move
so you can play rook a five probably
cheeks and I have something hanging as
well
good okay doesn't really do much my
queen I think I have to remove the Queen
in this position going to do one I think
94 still doesn't work because of 95 and
this night takes a force well I am so
late for wouldn't work and the ideas now
okay yeah I just went upon I just went a
whole yeah I think 996 okay okay then
let's play the move that I originally
intended to play ib5 I think I'm going
to prevent h4 for the moment this mean
more opportunities you know I can can
even up to the immediate reform
[Music]
so how to do it Queen f3 I played this a
little bit too hastily out of it it
wasn't super well timed and too early
Lescott Queenie Warner I overlooked this
completely I don't know if it really
hurts me but completely did not have it
on the radar yeah I try to UM speed up a
little bit and it didn't help them the
quality of my position all that much
yeah the question is what is that queen
doing and queen h3 and I don't think it
it it leads to all that much night c7 is
interesting but I can also just get some
attacking things going without
sacrificing just improve the position
and Queen d2 Bishop h6 and so on
interesting question is also if Knight
c7 and so on just as anything but this
is this is simple and probably not bad
time morning just take stuff
Oh interesting and I didn't see at all
whoa Jegs work not good yeah I mean
didn't see that I didn't see that either
Wow and wow I'm losing this game this is
crazy
this crazy
it was completely completely one-sided
game there's this thing hmm there's some
way to get this pawn back not really
it's amazing yeah cooing this up is
really quite amazing check
[Music]
check-check
[Music]
game come on that's really terrible oops
a terrible to draw this game which was
completely dominating the whole time
a blacks position is just completely
completely terrible the whole time him
yeah I just I don't know the timing you
probably wasn't right but yeah in this
eye you can never lose this position
really yeah I didn't see the tactic here
that's that the tactics thing on a three
I can play whatever I am I'm good it's
it's a completely dominating position
yes put its Queen on a terrible square
yeah and you can do really whatever
basically even here I just probably have
to go to c5 right I can just take why
can I just take this this because that
is just made okay so didn't even work
and yeah I was totally irritated I can
just take the fourth course and still
win probably mine was bad and we had
some some time-travel thing which I
should probably do this but oh okay
thanks for watching